this is what I worry about at all every
time I'm in the tunnel I worry about if
it collapsed if there was an accident
you have nowhere to go
how do you how do you make it safe
that's what I worry about how do you
make it safe tunnels are one tunnels are
exceptionally safe I mean are tunnels
designed to the highest California
seismic standards their gas proof water
proof in an earthquake for example
people often take what about an
earthquake one or cave-in it's like no
tunnels are the safest place to be in an
earthquake explain that the earthquakes
are primarily a surface phenomenon
they're like waves on the surface and
you can imagine like if you're in the
ocean you'd much rather be in a
submarine deep underwater then beyond
the surface if there's a hurricane it's
super quiet and underground in fact when
Mexico City had that terrible earthquake
roja massive number of people died but
the the subway tunnels where that we
used as a means of evacuation zero
people died in the subway tunnels you're
in our tunnel you were totally safe so
how do you know this Elon Musk how do
you know this I mean it's just one
Wikipedia such a way to find out this is
not a deep secret